this video of Beyonce and jay-z
courtside at Wednesday night's NBA
Finals is causing quite a stir in the
clip a woman is leaning over Beyonce to
talk to jay-z and fans were quick to
point out B's body language
noting she seems unamused by the
interaction and then she does this
little shoulder move wit ur highlights
include I would leave the earth as
beyonce looked this ready to smack me
beyonce is so annoyed by this woman and
hope gonna hear about it on the jet
beyonce Queen of the F out of here nudge
somebody better tell Becky she better
back up off beef with the so who is this
mystery woman she's actually Golden
State Warriors owner Joe lay cups wife
Nicole Curran she's president of the
Warriors Community Foundation and has
helped raise nearly nine million dollars
in grants to support educational equity
in the Bay Area I'm proud of when I
visit the schools and programs we
support in response to the be moment
Nicole's Instagram was quickly flooded
with a swarm of
he's prompting her to disable comment
she then posted a photo helping Beyonce
with something getting something out of
her hair it's hard to tell but she
captioned the photo we should all help
and support each other then on Thursday
morning her Instagram was switched to
private though the shade room did
capture a response she left in the
comments listen beehive I respect queen
bee I love her I talked to her husband
twice tonight all of this has been taken
out of context I'm a happily married
woman telling me to kill myself somehow
I don't think she would support this The
Beehive is always ready to bat for
Beyonce especially after the release of
lemonade in 2016 the album's narrative
was about infidelity in marriage but was
it an out-of-context viral moment or was
Beyonce really not having it let us know
your thoughts and be sure to subscribe
to all things et
[Music]